وائل يبدو ان خان يونس تتحمل العب الاكبر
في الساعات الماضيه ما اخر
[موسيقى]
التطورات هذا صحيح محمود باعتبارها اولا
هي ذروه العمليه العسكريه البريه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي لهذه العمليه
انعكاسات واضحه في سواء فيما يتعلق
بالغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه او بالقصف
المدفعي الذي هو جزء اساسي من اي عمليه
بريه او او حتى فيما يتعلق بالاشتباكات
التي تدور راحها في اكثر من محور اعنف
الاشتباكات التي استمعنا اليها خلال
الساعات الماضيه كانت في منطقه معا الى
الى الى الشرق من خانيونس من محافظه
خانيونس جنوبي قطاع غزه وايضا هناك محاور
اخرى في منطقه في في في منطقه شرق مدينه
خانيونس على اكثر من محور فضلا عن عن
الشمال الشرقي لخان يونس ايضا الذي يشهد
اشتباكات مختلفه مع عناصر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وواضح ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما تزال تحاول ان تتقدم قليلا
على بعض المحاور على الاقل ولكن كما يبدو
هذه القوات لم تستطع ان تتقدم او ان تحرز
اي تقدم في هذه المناطق خصوصا مع هذه
الاشتباكات وكما جاء في كثير من البيانات
التي صدرت عن كتائب القسام وسرايا القدس
وغيرها من الاذرع العسكريه فانهم يتحدثون
عن تنفيذ سلسله من العمليات والاستهداف
لاليات اسرائيليه وايضا لمراكز تحصن بها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مثل منازل
يحولوها الى مراكز استحكام في مناطق
خانيونس و فضلا بطبيعه الحال عن مناطق
تحشد الاليات والجنود الاسرائيليين الذين
يشاركون في هذه العمليه البريه المهم هم
ان اصوات الاشتباكات اصوات الانفجارات لا
تتوقف باتا في منطقه خانيونس على وجه
التحديد كما هو الحال خلال الساعه الماضيه
التي استمعنا الى اصوات قصف مدفعي مكثف
جدا في مناطق في قلب مدينه خان يونس ليس
فقط في مناطق في محافظه خان يونس وهي
الاوسع ولكن ايضا في قلب مدينه خان يونس
وكانت اصوات الانفجارات شديده وعاليه جدا
بمعنى انها ليست بعيده عن مجمع ناصر الطبي
الذي نتواجد فيه وهذا الامر ربما يتكرر في
كل ساعات الليل الماض في الايام الماضيه
حقيقه تنشط اصوات القصف المدفعي الغارات
الاسرائيليه اصوات الاشتباكات اصوات
الدبابات كلها يتم سماعها بشكل واضح جدا
لكن بالتاكيد هذا يعكس استمرار ال القوات
الاسرائيليه في استهداف هذه المنطقه هناك
سلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه خلال ساعات
اليوم قرب المستشفى الاوروبي وغرب مدينه
خان يونس وفي في مناطق متعدده كان واضحا
ان الطائرات المسيره
الاسرائيليه ربما تولت تنفيذ عدد من هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه ضد مجموعات من
المواطنين الفلسطينيين في اكثر من منطقه
في مدينه ومحافظه خانيونس الامر الذي ادى
الى سقوط اعداد من الشهداء واعداد من
الجرحى بعض هؤلاء الشهداء لم تتمكن سيارات
الاسعاف من انتشالهم او الوصول اليهم بفعل
انها انها كانت في اطار مناطق ساخنه مناطق
عسكريه تشهد اشتباكات ولا يسمح لسيارات
الاسعاف ولا لغيرها بالوصول الى هذه
المناطق المنطقه الاخرى التي تعتبر ايضا
مسرحا للاشتباكات الى حد ما ومسرحا ل
القصف الاسرائيلي الجوي والمدفعي هي منطقه
وسط قطاع غزه وتحديدا مناطق مخيمي المغازي
والبريج شرق محافظه خ محافظه وسط قطاع غزه
وايضا منطقه دير البلح التي شهدت استهداف
لاحد المنازل فيها خلال الساعتين
الماضيتين ادى الى سقوط ثلاثه شهداء سبعه
جرحى
كحصن بطبيعه الحال وايضا منطقه النصيرات
الزوايده المغرا وجحر الديك هذه كلها كانت
عرضه لسلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه فيما
يبدو بانها جزء مما تهدف اليه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بطرد سكان مخيمي
المغازي والبريج عن منازله والتوجه باتجاه
منطقه رفح جنوب قطاع غزه